Richard argana has relied on Manila Bay
for his daily catch for a decade and a
half he says he's been able to support
his family sufficiently with fishing as
his mean source of income
until two years ago when dredgers
appeared
there are times we go hungry so I
couldn't avoid borrowing money the fish
are gone because they've been Disturbed
neighbors who make dried fish say their
businesses have also taken a hit
fish has become more expensive but for
60 dollars before it's not worth 100 and
it's because fishermen are catching less
the economic hardship has forced the
community to take action on Tuesday
dozens of fishermen sailed around Manila
Bay in a show of solidarity against what
they say are destructive operations by
big corporations Manila Bay actually is
stretches beyond the capital now these
protesting fishermen who are sailing
with us and around us there from here
the province of Cavite but the fishing
Community is from two other provinces
have reported dwindling fishing stocks
and they're blaming dredging and
Reclamation activities
not far from where seabed quarrying is
taking place tons of sand is being
dumped on water the Philippine
environment Department declined Al
jazeera's request for an interview but
government data shows some 5 000
hectares have been approved for
reclamation
despite pollution scientists and
environmentalists say Manila Bay isn't
dead
there are areas we still have dimming
corals Rich coral reefs they have
sardines sardines spawning ground then
in Bulacan we have mangroves
in fact it's a major Flyway for wild
birds and some say it's also aggravating
the effects of climate change there's
also an apparent sea level
rice there are suffering from impacts of
flooding
since fishermen here started publicly
protesting the dredgers of their Coast
have left but a number remain anchored
in other areas of the bay new land and
Facilities may be necessary for a
growing population but many here Wonder
at what cost
partner below Al Jazeera Rosario Cavite
the Philippines